okay [ __ ] it's my psychobabble we are
back and I just literally have to take a
little bit what favorites well thank yet
again that's cool I got you that again
is here I you a mimic [ __ ] you up
is this a mimicked I'll [ __ ] you up I'll
[ __ ] all y'all [ __ ] up okay okay
nobody will just exploit an iPad not yet
not yet yeah over here now nothing looks
pretty [ __ ] long down a Beyonce scale
recording room now thank you Michael
upstairs I guess I can t [ __ ] in here
is Polly [ __ ] here now you [ __ ] with me
oh [ __ ] I will not drinking from a mimic
oh [ __ ]
pause that oh [ __ ] so you come to me I
will [ __ ] up your [ __ ]
you know let me tell you something a
kiss makes my day and a mile make my
whole week and
I know yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] how's a
[ __ ] mimic I'll [ __ ] break
all y'all fish how do I check my status
all data data data state Dave right and
I check my status what is it does that
mean oh there's too much [ __ ] here okay
[ __ ] I just broke that you'll mimic oh
yeah I am an ex polish
oh [ __ ] wait why does it say occupied
[Applause]
okay get out of here
oh [ __ ] anyhow
again I go upstairs right through there
let me say conference room right
oh there any gear okay okay all right
okay take this client clapping thank you
hi guys have to go mop it now
[ __ ] scary action yeah
not laying at the nigh bang yes yeah and
I could use some potato chips right
about now you know some salted chocolate
covered potato chips I love all your
[ __ ] I'm here
this guy jointed ready for your first
real view of the world
yes something killed this guy obviously
didn't commit suicide here so where's
that fires the mimic okay
a bunch of chant [ __ ] is that you need
to get to your office I've updated your
map there's a video you need to see I
know you have a lot of questions
oh they shed there's a lot of objects in
here okay
up hey guys it sank
[ __ ] it go run past it shotgun shells
the sticker should sister all the
[ __ ] objects off the [ __ ] Road
want to use the man attention station
leadership has issued an alert all
personnel should report to muster
stations immediately and await further
instructions
holy [ __ ] this guy asking
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna run around till
chants up oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] with look
where is that where is it where to land
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] your bed holy [ __ ] I
didn't think they'd be like [ __ ]
swanee in here
what extra I didn't even know when I
tried to pick up it was a call to [ __ ]
that was out here now
[ __ ] yeah that was not nice ah [ __ ] yep
I am gonna break shout break [ __ ]
yeah what is that
looks like shock of you
oh they shed
[ __ ] up now Detroit version zero point
seven three six online scanning target
Bill Bailey interior detective Kelly
Allen
sorry Bianca she's great pretty okay all
right let alone your comment with max
Detroit version zero point seven point
six online oh that is scary
that's a lot of chairs and a chance MA
oh there's Norma now that okay I'm
getting at time for the touch for sure
collapse our and my nobody yes I am yeah
my body
Oh leg shot deployed scanning target
you're drunk imagery okay
[Applause]
okay moon
holy [ __ ] is that man as a video files
there should I got it [ __ ] that
do it
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
20:30 Talos one becomes fully 2025 the
tret 1980 1962 1963 a top-secret 1950 to
1960 1982 1959 g20
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I better [ __ ] save say it was
all nothing
[ __ ] was that
okay
Oh morning hello as a reminder all
personnel must complete monthly
physicals during their stay aboard
towers one dr. DeVries promises to make
them as quickly oh thanks I'm [ __ ]
dyin I'm [ __ ] Diane Yin that [ __ ]
[ __ ] used and Betty I think that thank
you
okay
so I can save it again
oh [ __ ] that's it
too many objects down there for it to be
a locked door that mister you come with
me [ __ ] good I need help it all off
oh great oh great
[ __ ] barrels chasing after me [ __ ]
you buck
like
I thought it would keep them in that
form don't go chef
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
Holly shattered cherry bark an egg
three seven four eight
we go to your office is zero four five
one [ __ ] okay
[Music]
[ __ ] that now there's it break your
[ __ ] face and this way now [ __ ] okay
alright [ __ ] around
alright guys stare out for five bucks
oh [ __ ] okay I guess it's your turn to
come with me
welcome back this has been your home for
the last three years the video should be
on your workstation
Detroit version 2.7 26 online so let's
turn up a second
and we just have a long time to load on
future hello Morgan
tough day right so I'm talking to myself
it must be and your memories shot full
of holes I know I'm sorry but it's
permanent so the first thing you need to
know is you can trust January
it's an operator sort of backup of you
and me it knows what you've forgotten
we've been testing a new kind of neural
mod based on the type and organisms
mapping their neural patterns onto ours
problem is when you uninstall a neural
mod it resets your memory back to the
moment you first put it in that's why
you forget there supposed to be a
process to bring you back up to speed
between test runs but someone could just
skip that part turn a single day into
your entire life no that's exactly what
Alex did the question is why yeah why
that's you're not gonna like what I have
to say next
all right sorry I found every one of
those damn radios sorry but I can't let
you listen to that not until I've had a
chance to explain everything in person
for though just dammit I have to go just
sit tight please but sorry Morgan
Alec Scott I saw from the looking glass
servers time to improvise
I suggest you search dr. Calvino's
workshop in the hardware labs he
invented the looking-glass technology
you might find a way to restore the
server connections there I'm looking for
another way to help you in the meantime
good luck thanks max
okay I should we check all the [ __ ] that
part okay I guess I guess right yes my
aunt is up with it [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that I'm recycling wire that comes
back okay all right so where we going
now guys where are we going now okay
good morning fellas breakfast is served
in their attic area until 9:00 a.m. that
was in there and I get an act
fuckin'-a
when I was in here okay guys okay guys
let's go in here [ __ ] like bobbing
around okay let me get the second thing
I got here
that's great okay okay but I am just
taking a positive chefs everywhere with
me because then I like a fish or to be
doing this [ __ ] can I break it by
throwing around talking you're really
cute
detective but I just take testicle
[Music]
thank out fabricator power dispenser
thank you popular tech market for
[ __ ] with that Holly [ __ ] Detroit
version 0.7 free online checking for
updates service skimming talking you're
typing material
[ __ ] integrity - [ __ ] it my dick has
been sucked at experts October fine
back back back back back
I could fantastic
broken and they may have broken [ __ ]
need repair we're going to fly this
[ __ ] where is it where is it
requesting new operator smart pyramid
clinging on to your own medical consult
regularly fancy diagnosing superficial
injuries there be a portable bit I'll
have you feeling better still they're
all better
[Music]
how can I kill him okay maybe I'll use
minor amount or [ __ ] to repair
continue
okay okay
quit [ __ ] creepy yeah again there are
much
let's take here a [ __ ] fork that's
some [ __ ]
Oh socket
I got all [ __ ] up shine like that
[Music]
you're made two meters away from glass
no I'm gonna make [ __ ]
I'll have another faster if I would help
this guy out Hey look at airgun taking a
dick or something
[Music]
hello good to see you again doctor you
sure this game is con scary
alright [ __ ] [ __ ] say that for sure
what's back in nothing second Alex
algeri mom something scared borrow some
Emeka now your aunt had batch Oh
smellier
[ __ ]
qualified not [ __ ] mimicking here
another is selling on the task that
what's the damage
Oh
these psych evals are a waste of time a
waste of time life back on earth that
was different was it anger issues with
authority a year of counseling doesn't
sound like a trivial matter those files
were supposed to be closed are you angry
Oh Yankee reported in a new
relationships no both on you and miss
for a sanitation engineer was seen
together
she's a sanitation boss and we're not in
a relationship not anymore
how do you open a [ __ ] and this
separation did it involve anger issues
with a source group are you have an
appointment report we have to use I
don't care you're putting miss me at
risk just like Transtar north and just
like on earth side your ass holes will
be area with your psych eval [ __ ]
and another thing come in it's Sarah but
you can call me chief Eleazar
Mathias please forgive me but your name
is so high in the fire we've been over
this my mother unmarried I stood where
we be spending the next fifty nine beers
like this because we could cut it short
right now we've discussed your mother
I thought perhaps today we could speak
more about my career choices that were
born of that serving in the military
wasn't an excuse to get away from her
nagging met I was just Griff hello nice
to Rend you're better now not breasts
Messiah Kelsey nine because your last
tour of duty was the evacuation better
looking for other service questionnaire
at the front head for every soldier we
lost they're able to save a hundred
civilians yes
tragic ever needed please contact a
qualified or come here again here cost
was worth it both in lives and the
unification of the region taking on a
losing battle like that
fighting not enemy troops but the
equivalent of a natural disaster it
wasn't natural it was man-made
it prepared me for here dr. Cole because
this station it's the same thing a
disaster waiting to happen we are well
trained and poorly equipped yeah it's a
resistor reverse repair is needed please
contact a qualified engineer dangerous
I'm sure you would agree and I should
really get stuck in repair skill I came
in this way
all right right there
[ __ ] is this go back up what do I
collect don't even know my [ __ ] thing
is yeah check this cannon yeah yeah
pockets shut okay well there was a
computer terminal I think it was here
actually I wasn't yeah that like had
where everyone was oh [ __ ] what's in
there I wonder what the [ __ ] was that
I don't know
[ __ ] business [ __ ] that [ __ ]
okay security okay okay
[ __ ] I wish I had those [ __ ] turns
now wait
Tally's any elevator [ __ ] getting around
is going to be a problem the main lift
is broken
hmm the system is telling me it's fine
it's just the diagnostic code is
changing every time I make a request
I'll let you know if I find a workaround
then I go on restrooms now
here we go up and across don't Punk out
sooner
permit
can you let me know across the [ __ ] now
as it is taking off okay that's another
way I cannot go now like other ways to
get around you can go through like
[ __ ] walls and Chet Chet take on the
restrooms
I go through here again I like right
good that's a mimic
okay I'm gonna stay here yeah holy shet
good clock that definitely [ __ ] like
that fine up [ __ ] around okay eyes
and everything I could do here came and
do that way to ever get the time
I should say there's like a door on that
side okay enough to go to shuttle baths
great
I'll turn scanning target your type of
maturity no oxygen detected host [ __ ]
take it there boy like locked up I can I
might take a card other stresses come
with me
I want to know security
good morning Talos warning tampering
with administrative controls on
workstations or keypads
may result in electric shock if you're
having trouble accessing a system please
send a help alert to security [ __ ]
missing something
hey check out Chris waiting it was this
do let's take the map right
I haven't going to check that the side
Tronics foyer and then we got in here
Oh God
[ __ ] like advance or some [ __ ] I hear
another let me stay here
I was in here ready fun happen here
it's gotta be something on the second
floor so I'm sure right candy
okay so it's definitely not this side
[ __ ] can I get over it yeah oh [ __ ] I
can get over it over there okay one sec
let me get up they get much different
case
that's how it done okay all right I
might start back here
I'm counting fire nice talk about this
now okay so I got to go over there there
we go that makes sense now I jump still
with this yeah okay
I call that I'll I said [ __ ] it chef
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
can i really use [ __ ] it i'm reloading
last night so like me I'm just an
engineer and just an engineer Poppaea
fit funky little yes okay that happened
are you on your way on my way we're
Octavia didn't you city alert
we're supposed to muster listen it's
really sweet that you're worried about
me but we've had alerts before and I've
got three more of these glorified vacuum
cleaners to fix before my shifts over Oh
make that four someone dropped off
another things are junk I don't think
this is a drill anemia
I'm sending through the code please come
to the escape pods right now I bring all
that [ __ ] shut catch it in here okay
take this banana oh [ __ ] why did I do
that
right here a lot of chairs are there now
thank you
hello with my birthday yeah second Dan
topping Jax I guess buying in drama club
okay well I got the key card to the
pilots thing let us talk got that
good race I says sounds a legend what is
that fabricator
okay well I gotta say right I set the
file Dennis what step lounge is we just
went through
so same sort of deal clock now now how'd
it get in there tomorrow then we'll okay
I'd be a way to keep going right
all right I've got bench how's this
thing going for Oh No okay you got your
[ __ ] [ __ ] me yeah I don't factor
some [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] kind of [ __ ]
can I just not go in [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] look I make turkey card or some
[ __ ] I missed what is this okay there we
go
[ __ ] mr. keycard psych eval genius I
call that old okay there we go
there we go
Oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] where am I
okay I got Thank You Khan all right well
John this guy's mcdonough slow and
steady wins the race slobs that he was
hurt
there's another one isn't that that
straight-talking
you're trying to reach holy [ __ ] try to
last
[Music]
[ __ ] I just saw one
Oh
okay okay
all right boys we're gonna add a step
aside and I guess I guess stay lacks
ambition